[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
انقلاب لم يطبخ على نار هادئه بل على
نيران مشتعله لا تخمد بسهوله الخلاف بين
فاقنر والجيش الروسي يصطبغ بالدم الجيش
الروسي يقصف قوات
يوجه قواته صوب موسكو الاوضاع مشتعله جدا
في روسيا يا ساده الاليات تخرج الى
الشوارع والجيش يغلق المدن ويطفئ شبكه
الانترنت وموسكو تعلن حاله الطوارئ هل
توقعتم ان يحدث هذا كله بين ليله وضحاها
فجاه ودون سابق انذار حسنا ها هو يحدث
كثير منكم يقول انها خدعه روسيه مسيده
للغرب واوكرانيا فمن ذا يمكن ان يصدق ان
يحدث انقلاب ضد بوتين يا لها من معركه
غامضه لها بدايه وربما لن تكون لها نهايه
فما الذي يجري في روسيا اليوم كنا قد
تحدثنا في فيديو سابقا
[موسيقى]
امام العالم هذه المره متوعدا بالانتقام
عن اي انتقام يتحدث اذ قني صوب بوصله
اتهامه نحو الجيش الروسي مباشره ملتهما
اياه بقصف معسكرات قواته ونشر فيديو يوثق
لحظه قصف قواته ما اسفر عن مقتل عدد ضخم
من عناصره ليصب جمه غضبه على وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه متواعدا بالانتقام ويا له من
انتقام سيقود البلاد الى نتائج لا يحمد
عقباها لتظهر هنا لقطات لموكب بوتين يتحرك
نحو الكريم
[موسيقى]
وجه قوته نحو العاصمه موسكو ليطلب من
الجميع عدم المقاومه قائلا اطلب منكم عدم
المقاومه اي شخص يفعل ذلك سيعتبر تهديدا
لنا وسيتم تدميره ينطبق ذلك على اي نقاط
تفتيش طيران على طريقنا السلطه الرئاسيه
والحكومه والشرطه والحرس الروسي سيعملون
كالمعتاد الطباخ طمئن البلاد بان هذا ليس
انقلابا عسكريا بل المسيره نحو العداله
وهذا لا يؤثر على القوات الروسيه ولا على
العمليات في اوكرانيا كما قال وبينما يمضي
في قراراته واوامره تتحرك وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه على طريقتها الخاصه فتصدر بيانا
تطلب فيه من قوات فاجنر القبض على قائدها
والقوات الروسيه تنشر الدبابات والمعدات
الحربيه الثقيله في العاصمه موسكو تحسبا
لاي تمرد في العاصمه وفي ذات البيان نفات
الوزاره قصف قواتها لمجموعه
هذا ما حدث وما يحدث
او طباخ بوتين كما يطلق عليه اطلق سهامه
منذ مده فاصبح ينقل اخبارا عن تقدم قوات
اوكرانيا لم تجرؤ على نقلها الطباخ يقول
ان وزير الدفاع يخادع الرئيس بوتين ويضلل
الشعب الروسي فهناك روايتان يجري في
الميدان وما يتم اعلام الرئيس به واكد
تجري عمليات الحرب في اوكرانيا كما يراها
الطباخ وليس ذلك فحسب بل ان الطباخه يتهم
وزير الدفاع بانه امر باخفاء الفي جثه
لمقاتله في مشرحه خاصه لها من تهم خطيره
ومرعبه برايكم هل يقول الحقيقه ام ان له
مارب اخرى لنعد الى موضوعنا زاد الطين
بيله بقوله ان وزير الدفاع
الحرب في اوكرانيا ليحصل على قلاده بطل
روسيا
وها هو يضيف ان تخطيط النيتو واوكرانيا
قبل الحرب لمهاجمه روسيا امر مستند على
الاكاذيب التي ينفقها قاده الجيش الروسي
وصل به الحد لمعارضه اعلى هرم في السلطه
الروسيه وهذا لم ياتي من فراغ بل للقوه
التي باتت تشكلها فاجنر داخلي وخارجيا مع
ان يفجني صرح من قبل بانه لا يمتلك القوه
لمعارضه بوتين او مواجهته لكن ابواب
الكريملين قد تفتح امام يفجيني كزعيم هذه
المره او كاحد صناع القرار في البلاد وقطع
تجاوز عقبه هذا الامر الذي اقدم عليه
التوتر خرج عن نطاقه اخرج للعلم حجم
التصدعات العميقه في صفوف قوات الكريملين
باوكرانيا والنجمه هذه المره هي تمرد
مجموعه باجنر فمن جهه اجبر وزير الدفاع
الروسي
المجموعه على القتال برغم نقص الذخيره
وبعد الانتصار استبدل المجموعه بقوات احمد
الشيشانيه وكان شيئا لم يحدث اما اليوم
وبعد خطوه تجديد الاجراءات الامنيه في
موسكو وتم وضع جميع المرافق الاكثر اهميه
وسلطات الدوله ومنشات البنيه التحتيه
للنقل تحت حمايه معززه وفق وكاله تاسع
الروسيه الطائرات حلقت بكثافه في مدينه
رستوف وبدات وحدات الحرس الوطني باغلاق
الشوارع وزاره الدفاع الروسيه وهيئه
الاركان العامه الروسيه والجهاز الامن
الفيدرالي الروسي يوجهون لجنه للتحقيق
فتصريحات وافعاله طعنه في ظهر الجيش
الروسي كما هو واضح لديهم جزار بوتين
الجنرال تدخل ليطلب من جنود فاجنر حل كل
شيء بشكل سلمي نحن من نفس الدم نحن
محاربون لقد قاتلنا سويا العدو ينتظر تدور
الوضع السياسي الداخلي في البلاد لا يمكنك
اللعب في ايدي العدو قوموا بحل الوضع بشكل
سلمي الانباء عن جهاز الامن الفيدرالي
الروسي تقول ان تصريحات وافعال بريكوجين
هي في الواقع دعوات لبدء نزاع مدني مسلح
على اراضي الاتحاد الروسي من جهه اخرى
وزاره العدل الروسيه ستقدم تقييما قانونيا
صحيحا لتصرفات بريكوجين وفي حال ثبتت
التهمه سيسجن زعيم فاقنر لمده قد تصل الى
20 عاما
لا يصمت ويتولى الرد بنفسه ويقول انه
سينقل قوته الى موسكو لمعرفه سبب الفوضى
في البلاد وعلى الجيش الروسي الا يعترض
طريقهم الخطوه المقبله بيد باجنر التي
ستقرر الرد على هذا الفعل بعيدا عن اطراف
الازمه والمتحدث
باسموف يؤكد ان الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين على
علم بما يدور حول مؤسس مجموعه فاجنر
لافتان الى انه يجري اتخاذ جميع الاجراءات
اللازمه وبين هذا وذاك اختلطت الاوراق
وتشابكت القوات بكلامها وتصريحاتها قبل ان
تشتبك على الارض لكن وسط التوترات الحاليه
في روسيا لا شيء
عملياتهم العسكريه في اوكرانيا فها هي
قاذفه القنابل الاستراتيجيه الروسيه اطلقت
صواريخ كروز من بحر قزوين باتجاه اوكرانيا
والجيش الاوكراني يعلن حاله التاهب القصوى
فضلا عن التقدمات على الارض كما اعلنت
القوات الروسيه فكل شيء في بابه كما
يقولها العرب طباخ بوتين اشعلت داخل
الروسي كما اشعل الخارج من قبل ومع كل هذه
التوترات ما الذي ستؤول اليه نتائج افعال
الطباخ هل سينجو بفعلته هذه برايكم ليصبح
الرقم واحد في روسيا بعد الرئيس بوتين
ولكن لا نستبعد ان هذه الازمه قد تكون
حيله مفتعله لاكتشاف الجواسيس الخفيين
الذين سينضمون الى بريغوجين ليقدمهم عن
ذهب طباخ على طبق من ذهب امام بوتين
[موسيقى]